Lady gentleman, black helicopters
have been spotted. Yeah.
Nobody balls harder than them.
Yeah. It's pretty out of control.
Every week goes Ferrari's, Bentley's
Lamborghinis. There's like ridiculous.
There's cars that I feel like it
would be ridiculous to show up.
Why about one of those Bentley's that
they have or one of those Bugattis rather
than they have as a police car for sure.
It's in Santa Ana.
Two and a half million bucks. Yeah. So
much. I think flug mother has like six.
He has so many. He's hilarious. His
building habits are hilarious. I love him.
And he's got like a whole fleet of list
in white. He's like white is right.
I got a bunch of two though.
Man. Does gang or cars? Oh Man.
You owe that money to the IRS.
Wanted to just give him a few
thoughts because he went so deep.
So how much does he owe? Well, uh,
it's more than you want to pay.
It's in the 20 plus million dollar
range. It's a lot of money, man.
But it's not something that he's
been, uh, it's not like deception.
No, it's just neglect to, to pick
black. And it's also like, I think,
and there is like a truth to this,
he makes so much money.
There's probably a point when they're
like, hey, it's time to pay your taxes.
And you go like, all right,
here's a check for $25 million.
That's an incredible amount of
money. And then they go, that's true,
but you owe 50 more. And he's just
like, that's, that can't be right.
I've got $25 million. Yeah. Like
what are you talking about man?
He's bought over a hundred luxury cars
and the same dealer and always pays and
cat oh areas. I love it. 15
million worth of car congratulated.
She doesn't drive. I like it.
Good. You could sell those.
They're worth a lot of money. He can get
that money to, you know, it's um, it's,
it's just, it's, it's,
he's really interesting in the amount
of money that is able to generate,
you know, he's figured out
some pretty incredible shit.
He's a great villain to man.
Oh,
he's just brilliant at it and he's
just a brilliant defensive boxer. Oh,
skill wise.
Off the charts off the truck.
We're saying that guy should get more
credit for what he does as a skilled
businessman and psychological warrior.
Like he should get a lot more credit for
it. Yeah, I think so too. I think it's,
it's arguable that,
you know,
he's enjoying it and he let enjoys
playing the villain role and enjoys like
flashed on the money and if
he is really enjoying it,
like don't you love that and respect that,
that fucking thing. What is that car?
That thing looks amazing.
My new 4.4 what is it?
A CCX XR. Is that a con of Sig?
Yeah. I didn't say that cone.
That's a word that I've never said. I
Amy me. I can't say it. I love him too,
that he starts his post with the amount,
like to remind people that my new car.
Yeah, my new four point $8 million car.
You think you say that Koeneke Sig
Koenigsegg clinics coincide coding,
coding, coding, cone Ne Koenigsegg.
Jesus Christ. Koenigsegg CC.
That's a ridiculous name.
Change the name. The car is dope. You're
working same correction. I think so.
Yeah. Working during this fight. Oh yeah.
I'm in d c both still working during this
fight. You were headed already. Me Too.
I already booked way in advance.
Now it's my dad's birthday.
I'm going to a big birthday celebration
and I tried to avoid finding out what
happened and then watching. No, it depends
man. It's I we haven't, I don't know.
I'm going to gauge also his
interest in it. You know?
I always try to get home before I find
out anything or watch it before I find
out anything and I always fail to do
so. You always think, can I give it?
I give any temptation it happened. I know
how to, I know it's hard. I go online.
Let me check real quick.
Yeah. Am I worthwhile?
Like what if they tell me it's a
five round boring decision, you know,
have a title fight on.
This one's going to be 12 rounds boxing.
I know it's going to be, it's exciting
event. It's one of those like you,
you'll remember like the excitement
to tune in. So I think we,
we were going to want to watch it.
You know Conor McGregor is a magic person.
Yeah.
Like legitimately I to get this many
people so hyped up about this fight.
Yeah. It's not just about
his performances, his fights.
It's also about like wanting to believe
that there's a dude who could pull it
all off. Yeah. It's like a magic person.
Do you feel like in the lead up to
the fight, like as we get closer,
your opinion on it has changed at all? Oh
yeah. I'm a sucker for a good hype job,
dude. That's why I'm a good
hype man. Right, right. Yeah.
I'm a sucker for believing
all that stupid shit.
Okay.